Hey Youtubers happy 2017, so new wonder woman
footages hyping up.
The God killer swords of the action of the
film.
Some explain what what that is because really
cool weapon.
There is a new round of the flash ring giveaway
to all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss anything.
Most of this is just hyping up like the crazy
action of the film.
Most international trailers.
Which ever country they're dropping them in
her whichever language there in 10 to hypes
the action just because you don't need to
speak a foreign language to understand wonder
woman stealing the God killer sword or punching
someone in the face or just spinning all over
the screen kicking so much as.
So thankfully we get some new footage but
this is cut out of water like you see wonder
woman watching Steve Trevor's plane crash
at the beginning but then it jumps all the
way to the German soldiers rushing the Amazons
on the beach which seems like it happens much
later in the film.
The only reason for the Germans the Kaiser
this is World War I so were talking about
the Kaiser here to want them is Keira is because
of some resource that the Amazons might have.
They do have a mother box in their possession.
But they haven't really explain how much of
the Darkside war there can explain during
the wonder woman movie within the context
of the DCEU, we know that there are three
mother boxes on the earth with someone of
the Justice league trailer and we saw Lex
Luther learning about them at the end a Batman
be Superman
that thing that Lex Luther's getting all the
information from the supposed to be Steppenwolf
or lease of the kryptonian computers Etch-a-Sketch
version of Steppenwolf.
So this is really like the kryptonian ship
speaking to him this is it actually Steppenwolf
speaking to him.
He's learning based on the kryptonian database
about dark side in all these other galactic
threats that kind of informed his character
little bit but they cut that out of the main
movie that everybody saw in theaters is in
the ultimate addition though so full circle
back around of that because that explains
why Lex Luther was being so crazy in the Batman
view Superman movie.
But aside from like the brief explainer that
Zack Snyder gave us a long time ago about
the earth's history with dark side.
We don't really know how that's gonna carry
forward into the other spinoff films presumably
will see another mother box show up during
the Aqua man movie because there are a couple
other ancient races of people including the
Amazons and the Atlantean's that would have
been around for the first big fight with dark
side.
So it's not like the German troops want to
take them is Keira, just because they need
a new vacation spot.
There's gonna be some sort of resource it's
going to help them conquer the world in the
legend of a mother box would just be one of
those things.
But that's taking a day in Houston is like
the big villain of the film.
So whatever the reason for them attacking
you would flow from him, but it seems like
it's happening after all these other weapon
test to happen later in the trailer like we
slowly see the Germans experimenting with
poison gas.
That's really kind of like mustard gas that
was like the real big chemical weapon of World
War I. It would like completely scar people's
faces.
It was really bad even for people wearing
gas masks.
This is what they're implying here and I know
a lot of people were wondering who this person
is here because people like his Aries in the
film, he's like wonder woman's biggest villain.
I don't know that Danny Houston is playing
Aries in disguise.
He could totally be Aries, but it seems like
he's just a really evil German officer right
now.
This looks like it's Doctor poison, just because
Doctor poison is a big wonder woman villain.
Her family has a long history of fighting
against the Amazons in the comics so she has
a big grudge against them.
So you kinda get the idea.
Just you know from these trailers that the
Amazons want have anything to do with the
outside world like Hippolytus standing next
to wonder woman here doesn't want have anything
to do with Steve Trevor wonder woman herself
and all explained.
The God killer sword in the second because
is a really bad ass quote from Athena on it.
Wonder woman herself has to defy orders because
in a she kinda flows from the quote on the
sword here.
You can't really read it in these trailers.
But such a quote they borrow from Joseph Campbell
and it's from mysteries of the feminine divide
and it reads life is killing life all the
time.
And so the goddess kills herself in the sacrifice
of her own animal.
So the goddess is referring to is Athena Athena's
animal form is like a deer or a stag so it's
sort of a lament that as you kill other people
you're also killing yourself little bit so
it's like the tragedy of war, which flows
a lot from what's happening with World War
I so the try to get really meta-with the war
theme of the film wonder woman is a warrior
she's like one of the biggest warriors in
the Justice league even though everybody's
a bad ass in the Justice league wonder woman
herself walks around carrying a shield and
a sword of the sword itself does have special
properties.
It's called the God killer sword because it's
Athena sort, but also as you use it to take
life.
You're killing the goddess Athena.
Do you have to imagine that wonder woman is
really sad at the thought of having to kill
people, so they believe all life is sacred,
which is why she believes Steve Trevor and
wants to help him and World War I, but because
of where we meet her and Batman be Superman.
We know that probably doesn't end well, just
because even though she's been living in the
real world.
She's retreated from public life since the
end of this wonder woman movie wherever this
leaves off back in 1918.
So like the way sex that are explained it
is that when we meet wonder woman in Batman
view Superman she's kinda believing a very
private life, for the past hundred years.
So it just imply something really terrible
happens at the end of this movie.
Probably to Steve Trevor.
Just because he's the love interest in her
whole mission is to try and bring peace to
the world something.
Some scholars insist but I can also to me
it's the combination for company find sort
of ethics on the blade.
The 40 and not it's a Pacific so over the
bed of this
there was actually this big thing last year
where like the character wonder woman became
this big figure at the United Nations wonder
woman herself as a character is a peacemaker
even though she will totally kick people's
asses, but Linda Carter and Gallagher.actually
did this big United Nations thing, so that
had a lot to do with the 75th anniversary
of the wonder woman character so I'll be really
interested to see you with the political climate
what it is how they try to use the wonder
woman character to market the film internationally
like everyone saying that 2016 was the year
of zero chill the maybe wonder woman will
try to change that in 2017, but I know a lot
of you are asking about like post credits
like we have Justice league coming in November.
Does that mean that there's gonna be a Justice
league Post credit in present day at the end
of the wonder woman movie, so they don't really
show you in this trailer, but in the previous
trailers we actually see her walking by the
Louvre in present day in France of the Diana
Prince persona that she walks around using
during present-day is an antiquities dealer.
So it sounds like either at the beginning
of the film or at the end of the film there's
a remembrance of things that happen and then
they flashback but either way the film does
take place during present-day and then back
during the past, most of the film is back
during the pastor.
During this World War I.
So what can happen later tonight is, they
just confirmed that Doctor strange is going
to be in important part of Thor Ragnarok and
we know he was can be somewhere in there but
I'll do a video explaining what's going on
with that it can be a lot of fun.
Benedict Cumberbatch Chris Hemsworth and Mark
Ruffalo the hold.
Doctor strange and Thor teaming up.
It can be awesome.
So I will say congratulations to this week's
flash ring giveaway winner Luis Diaz please
private message me on the back and my channel
so I can get your contact details.
There is a new round that started in this
video so.
Just announce the winner the next time I post
a DC video, which will probably be the flash
that should be Wednesday morning while you
guys wait for that to post you can click here
for my 2017-trailer for like all the big stuff
that's coming and you can click here to learn
why everyone's freaking out about the Batman
movie that you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys tonight!